you
hi everyone it's Jerry Aman chess calm
and I just got paired up playing a 3-2
game in matrix algebra 1 let's try for a
Kings Indian attack against the French
all right 92 black could okay they're
not gonna go for it sometimes there's a
capture and then a quick e5 so see if I
could go after the black king okay black
is electing to deploy their night there
huh so I won't be able to get an e5 with
some tempo let's get castling in and now
a little bit of a moment to think here
or to e1 yet probably rook to e1 next
night to h4 might be an idea to then
think about expanding with f4 and so
maybe I have a little bit of a decision
here my next move okay they're going
there I think I like this idea
especially now since they've weakened
their light squares this might be an
idea queen h5 look to soften up their
Kings side I expect castles maybe I
could get in f4 f5 I don't I'm not sure
exactly about that shift in the
structure but yeah main main idea with
this is to get enough for mm should I go
with that 5 I'm not quite sure but uh I
think this is a good idea set forth upon
duo let's give it up let's give it a
shot
this Knight is restricted this pawn on
d5 has some pressure on it twice hmm not
quite sure what to do it my d2 night I
like to see this pawn flinch don't know
if I can make that happen
c4 would really weaken d4 don't want to
do that
I don't know if this is correct playing
f5 I could give it a shot
mmm I think after just captures I'm not
I don't know what the great follow up
would be I'm gonna kind of play a little
bit of a waiting game I think my king is
a little bit safer on each one not quite
sure what to do with my pawn duo so
let's make a quick move kind of like a
passing move non-committal move let's
see what black does Queen c7 is a nice
way to improve I think you know Queen c7
rook a to eat are nice useful moves and
I'm kind of running out of yeah useful
moves
yeah Queen c7 so I'm gonna have to make
a decision at some point hmm maybe c3
just roll out Knight to d4 mm-hmm let's
give that a shot
c3 maybe I could consider moving this
Knight but I'm a little bit fearful of
my knight getting stranded if I step on
f3 he's kind of short on squares maybe I
could play Queen h5 just to see how they
react
maybe induce some weakening move Queen
h5 Bishop here okay
hmm I kind of like seeing that move I
don't think Knight c4 is a good idea
let's just go here they have a space
advantage on the Queen side a knight c4
move will be kicked with a b5 I could
slow it down for a little bit but in
time I can't really rely upon the c-4
square for my knight and prep moves a6
b5 King move there so Queen here let's
actually rule at night b5 first night b4
hmm okay I may actually think about
playing a four I think I actually like
that because they have a space advantage
on the Queen side I think I want to lock
down on the Queen side here a four-night
b1 a3 b5 do I have time for that
hmm do I have some concern about g5 I
think that's they might be lining that
up and this and so this idea playing on
the queenside is probably a bit too slow
g5 and on takes maybe they take
advantage of the fact that I'm behind a
development these guys aren't playing
just yet
mm-hmm maybe yeah actually
actually this is being lined up I'm not
even winning upon so maybe I should play
Knight to f3 nor I kind of like this
move Queen h5 Bishop here to chase her
away but then I'll play to e2 and claim
just a hair of success they
underdeveloped and I play Queen e2 as if
I just developed they'll have to move
that Bishop again so ok Queen to e2 it
is now this is weakened okay they took
care of that now maybe I could consider
this f5 move or maybe still revisit this
idea of a4 and then sink my knight in to
b5
I like this mm-hmm got to make a
decision quick well I have time for that
I'm going to reason that I do have time
for that let's give it a shot maybe one
night a3 Bishop d2 if I have a few more
moves I like my position also with my
knight not on d2 g5 is harder to get in
and this would actually be a much mmm
they'd have a much more weakened King
position let's go for this beef night b4
I think he's it's a nice square for the
knight but mmm maybe maybe we both end
up with pieces that are on good squares
but I don't know this bishop would be
tucked back is my knight maybe out of
play he's in a good on a good square but
I don't know maybe I could try to
connect him in some way a knight on b5
connected with e5 they're less than 20
seconds didn't consider that move I
think I have to take let's
and I guess go right in for a night to
be five what else is he gonna do I came
this way I came this way for a reason if
you say a and B I guess you have to go
with C I'm not taking with the pond
that's surprising
I guess their king is going to start to
book go in this direction huh oh that's
a super surprising move huh
all right plane f5 I don't want to give
this square up okay this has to be good
for me yeah I'm going to take with the
pawn mm-hmm
you know secret the pond are they gonna
play E for I think they have to I could
have also taken the bishop that's
surprising I think they should have
played e5 some type of pawn sack now
this Knight tricky guy tricky guys that
night let's go like this push g5 be very
direct let's keep going and play on the
G file I'm hitting the rook let's get
here get my other rook working let's go
here less than 10 for me and just pile
up on the G file throw my knight in here
timely Knight move triple up triple
trouble that can't work you know just
sneaking in now huh I want to take with
the piece and they resigned it was too
much pressure
hmm you know this is I don't know
not sure to say here let's go into the
analysis real quick
well nothing I'm I'm not gonna bring up
stock fish just yet but right around
this moment I mean clearly you heard I
wasn't quite sure what to do
non-committal move King h1 I have to
make a decision at some point
I wonder if well for one these yeah
these structural you know these pawn
advances are are certainly
the Moose to investigate and we'll have
a look at them but I don't know that
this really helped black I think they
would have done better to still sit with
this d5 pawn retains some possibilities
of a capture or our push for my part I
don't see myself capturing on d5 I don't
know I think they should leave that pawn
sitting maybe get one more useful move
in rook a to e8 play it maybe a little
bit slower I felt a little bit
comfortable after this slight shift
after the C and D files were kind of
locked down and I think a direction
black could go for or a direction black
can go in is maybe starting with 8 4
actually and then try for a b5 break
playing on the side where they have a
space advantage and still leave this and
this pawn duo right here to combat these
guys be interested to see what kind of
tactics were missed I wonder a little
bit about I mean they played King h8 and
I assumed it was prepping some strike
with g5 and maybe even some sacrifices
on these dark-squared g3 maybe the Queen
sweeping down here hitting the night
hitting d3 I don't know these things
were running through my mind I wasn't
able to really voice them during the
game but uh-hmm
it was tough to really come up with a
plan I think we were both experiencing
that that feeling in the game you know
we're about throwing our King in here to
the corner squares h5 Queen e2 you know
I guess this is our right maybe this
decision was a bit too much they did
take some time on that recapture I think
holding the structure as you know
keeping it as is important I think they
had it in their mind where they were
going to run you know in this direction
and then maybe
on the h-file you know if they have
enough time that that's that's something
you know I'd have to be on the lookout
for but mm-hmm I think that that was the
reasoning at least that black gave for
this capture they wanted to eventually
have their King here and throw the rooks
in the H file and look to attack my king
but there's a lot of a lot of time
needed for that mm-hm
something to b5 I expected actually the
bishop to just drop all the way back and
kind of say you know what yeah your
knight isn't a good square but you know
this Bishop is is fine where he's out
he's still functioning on a pretty good
diagonal and there isn't really I could
follow up with a knight although as
mentioned I was considering tying a
piece or trying to connect him in some
way with a 5 and then maybe Knight to d6
at some stage is a nice jumping point he
didn't do that just play it there yeah
and I think this starts to no favor me
after the e5 push and maybe this is a
very important moment I took with the
pawn hoping a little bit of hope chess
here but I think II for might actually
be a move as soon as II four was not
played I think I'm just immediately
better I might be better already at this
stage after the capture but this is the
move that worried me because so many
pieces are brought to life the rook the
rook and the bishop and the night
they're all brought to life they have
the potential to make use of this square
winning upon but it's a little bit
uncomfortable that's and how I feel
maybe it's not enough I mean I'm
threatening to take and then deploy my
Bishop to the f4 square I'm not quite
sure there's something I'm going to
definitely take away from this from a
structural standpoint but once this
position is achieved the bishop on e4 is
and just enormous there's nothing
happening here on the
on the e-file and I could look to play
exactly how I did in the game with the
Jeep on push open up the G file and then
triple up with the major pieces there
okay well let's confirm things with the
computer and see where we can make some
improvements ok stockfish let's see what
we can learn from you I'm running now
with slight adjustment you can notice on
the right this is now stockfish seven
it's apparently about sixty Ehlo
stronger than the last version so okay
we're having it this is just another
another system here I've seen this
before connecting the Knights like this
as mentioned Knight to f5 will mmm no
excuse me knight on f6 can sometimes run
into an e5 advanced with tempo this is
sidestepped hmm let me just go back for
one moment it likes it like to have six
but yeah this is a system for sure on
the black end where is there a big leap
here I mean this is I was pretty much
locked into just this one idea Knight h4
and then get my F pawn rollin computer
likes to just take maybe this is
slightly there maybe this is too soon
is it not mm-hmm this is a far more
committal move than castling isn't it
so going with the least committal move
first probably best
so that suggests castles here these are
just little details but in more details
how I could consider capturing and then
playing c4 and now there's some gaps
here yeah you know what what's one thing
to quickly point out with f6 e 6 is now
a hole and capturing like this maybe
there's no way to take advantage of that
square in time and it likes that c4 idea
a knight on e4 quite strong
okay I didn't even think about capturing
on d5 at this stage Oh at night h4 and
this f4 idea like c4 I think right
around this moment I said c4 and I'm not
so sure it gives up d4 well c4 do you
take C Knight take see my positional
mindset I don't like having this
backward pawn but uh white is looking
for a piece play here I guess that's the
the idea to grant this night that was on
d2 and obstructing my Queen side
development get him out of the way and
do so it's tempo and then play Bishop to
e3 okay it's just another idea to be
aware of their a move that helps in
other words the c4 movement a move that
will help well puts pressure on d5 and
maybe I get a new square for my knight
and I could find the complete
development I went with king - h1 is
mentioned I wasn't quite sure a little
bit of a waiting move there the little
passing move and b3 I played c3 here
yeah it still gives a slight +4 black
that move it does not like it did pop up
for a moment Knight c4 but I figured
what am I talking about
he's not gonna be chased away I could
track down the bishop pair with that
move it still likes black ever so
slightly yeah I can't really pretty much
just even call it I think in large part
because of this space advantage the
strong pawn on d4 in my position okay I
closed it up it's not like that idea
ie five right away I'd came they're
still holding into Vantage Eve I've
what's the trick here f5 seems appealing
mm-hmm well I don't know I have to give
this one some time to think
I don't know how how much we can rely
upon a computer assessment in such a
position where where it's so locked I
mean the the clear the clear plan
here from a structural standpoint we'll
be black looking to expand on the
queenside and strike that's c4 this is
where they have a space advantage to
notify this pawn in my position on the
queenside whereas I'm looking for a g5
advance so it's a kinks my race I'm
looking to play on the kingside looking
to form a pawn duo like so black will
look to strike like this it's a big race
timing will be a great factor I don't
know I don't know how that would turn
out like in the computer's eyes yes it's
giving an advantage for black but might
be a bit a bit scary to play for plaque
actually no you know one wrong slip and
it's their king I'm attacking and
they're still there playing on the Queen
side so it's kind of tough to weigh okay
played King h8 played a three stops
night before you know I'm just doing
this to provoke something maybe g6 maybe
force a retreating move it's not forced
but I gained just a little bit with that
sequence of moves Bishop there be five
keeps calling out for this ePHI but I
kind of be scared to do that
b5 f5 and then throwing that pawn all
the way up there I don't know about that
now even it has it as even here with
this e5 idea for black plate a4 it still
likes this e5 idea but I still like this
reply yeah again look at how lock this
is this would be a direction I'm going
in in we even just saw a shift there and
it's so locked can't rely too much on
this evaluation those locked positions
opens up it's a much different story
maybe one there's time for these under
developing those because of the closed
nature of the position Knight to be 183
we exchanged it likes Bishop takes pawn
takes
not really liking pond takes so they
should keep the structure as is within
night b5 I expected just bishop back
it's quite natural
you know we just go from here we're
still we're still moving very cautiously
we don't know how exactly the positions
going to open up given some time I'd
like to just play Bishop d2 and get my
other rook working you know yeah I don't
see that this space advantage over here
you know with this ID of the a4 and
sinking my idea to b5 this play on the
Queen side is shut down and so this I
see it as I kind of interpret this as
well now that the Queen side has shut
down this will buy me time to play on
the Kings side where I have a slight
space advantage these two fourth-ranked
pawns versus blacks to third rank pawns
okay so they took with the pond it's not
like that and now a big moment coming up
here after f5 takes it likes eat takes
that's what I did in the game and this
was my concern so I guess it isn't
hitting efore is not working you know I
just I just felt that it was a little
bit loose because if I take with the
bishop and I pretty much have to I don't
want to take with the pawn and give them
a connected past pawn but I'm in a pen
there's new squares available for the
pieces it just felt a little bit mm a
little bit of a loose position but I
guess it's still fine computers
continuations to drop back with an
Bishop f4 you know I guess there's this
is fine there's not a good way to really
take advantage of the pin that I'm
currently in okay and I think we're
going to see a great shift now after
night before Bishop b4 is strong and we
are seeing a growing advantage now so
yeah it's it's it's growing pawn and a
half now okay King over and this is just
much
easier to play I mean black is lacking a
plan at this stage just push with g5 you
know space advantage and we're just
seeing the evaluation go crazy
there was even calling out for a mate
here mate in 10 you know okay yeah they
resigned here the idea here is I just
never want to take with the pond
I want to crash through with a piece and
that's going to be mate soon and a calls
for a night here but suppose just night
see - what's the winning idea rip takes
Bishop takes Queen takes Queen here oh
and then f6 everything is brought to
life it's the Queen and okay yeah now
the threat is Queen h6 and then mate so
this is uh this is guarding the h7
square with the bishop now rook takes F
and then me in one - yeah so it's just
collapsing the idea don't even allow
this pawn don't even allow the king till
it's a hide behind upon I devoted all
this time to set up the major pieces on
the G file so you don't want to block
them in by capturing with the pawn and
then have black hide behind that guy
okay well interesting game out of this
Kings Indian attack as usual feel free
to leave any feedback in the comments
section below to this video and as usual
I hope you got something out of it
that's all for now take care bye
you